في الاثناء يصطاد رئيس الامريكي السابق
ترامب لحج انصاره في جورجيا
لاستئناف حملته الانتخابيه رغما رغم
الدعاوى القضائيه لكن كيف يمكن ان تؤثر
لتهامات الاخيره على فرص ترامب في سباق
نحو البيت الابيض هذا هو سؤال المرحله
يقول خبراء ان الملاحقه القضائيه
داخل الحزب الجمهوري لاسيما حاكم فلوريدا
القوي راندي سنتس ونائبه السابق في توجيه
سهام الانتقاد بحقه حيث وجد منافسه ترامب
الفرصه سانحه الان للترويج بان ترامب وهو
المرشح الاوفر وفقا لاستطلاعات الراي
الاخيره حتى الان غير جدير بتمثيل
الجمهوريين لمنافسه بايدن في انتخابات 20
24 ويرى مراقبون انه على الرغم من الالات
التي تلاحق ترامب فان هذا لن يمنعه من
الترشح لكنها ربما ستمثل نقطه تحول في
حملته للانت التمهيديه ومع اشتعال الصراع
الانتخابيه مبكرا يبدو ان راندي سنتيس
والذي اظهر الدعم في تصريحاته الاخيره
لترامب لن يفوت الفرصه للنيل من غريمه شان
جارديان استاذه العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
سيركيوز قالت ان ديسانس سيستغل المتاعب
القانونيه في جذب اكبر عدد ممكن من مؤيد
ترامب لكسب ثقتهم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات